tennis champion Serena Williams is a
powerhouse when it comes to her sport
and her fashion line and motherhood but
she's also using her status as a force
for good Williams is now the national
ambassador for the Allstate Foundation
purple purse program they released this
PSA which has light on financial abuse
it's a serious issue that's affected a
very close friend of hers our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan spoke to
Williams about this issue Eureka good
morning would you learn good morning I
learned that this is an issue a lot of
people aren't talking about the national
network to end domestic violence's
financial abuse occurs in nearly all
domestic violence cases it's a fact that
got the attention of Serena Williams
who's lending her voice to a campaign
about the warning signs she's fierce on
the court with the nearly 25 year
professional tennis career that includes
23 Grand Slam singles titles and four
Olympic gold medals but Serena Williams
one of the most successful female
athletes in the world is giving voice to
an issue rarely talked about I had no
idea what financial abuse was when I
read that 99% of domestic violence do
involve financial abuse I felt like that
was a really really high number and it's
shocking financial abuse is defined as
an abuser taking control of finances to
prevent the other person from leaving to
maintain power in a relationship
Williams says she's seen the impact not
for herself and her friends a really
close friend of mine was going through a
situation that wasn't really healthy for
her wasn't hopefully for her friends or
her family and it was difficult to tell
her and then I realized like oh my
goodness she's all the songs and I was
learning about with financial abuse she
was involved in it was really intense
your partner takes credit cards out in
your name and maxes them out that's a
sign Williams teamed up with the
Allstate Foundation to release an ad
called signs to help educate people
about financial abuse and I was married
I wasn't allowed to control the money so
I didn't have access to the checking
account
Shelly DeVito says she knows the sign
firsthand for 17 years she was married
to a man she says financially abused her
I had to get permission to buy groceries
I was told what stores to go to to buy
various items I had to turn in the
receipt when it was given to me the
preschool teacher rarely told anyone
anytime I said anything people would say
did he hate you Lisi doesn't hate you
and so it does make you feel shame and
make you think wow maybe it's not that
bad she says it was her children that
gave her the courage to leave my kids
were 11 and 14 at the time and I was
like I I what am i showing my 14 year
old son I didn't want him to think that
this is how a man treats a woman and I
didn't want my daughter to think that
this is what we do that were submissive
to a man DeVito took her now ex-husband
to court claiming he financially abused
her he denied all her allegations in his
court filings and financial abuse is one
of the main reasons victims of domestic
violence can't leave over 3 million
children will witness domestic violence
how important is that when you think
about your own family when you think
about your role as a mother and putting
your voice behind a cause like this I
feel like a responsibility to make
people know more about things like
financial abuse and how to avoid it like
I want to teach my daughter everything
about it and if I have more kids and
ever happen to have a boy I want to
teach him about it so he is not a part
of the problem and only adds to the
solutions I do have more times now where
I feel strong and empowered by my
choices my DeVitto now shares her story
with domestic violence survivors many of
them have experienced financial abuse
when you feel invalidated disrespected
afraid silenced verbally emotionally
sexually financially or physically
abused it's not a healthy relationship
and you need to leave for yourself for
your children and for your life and
Ricca joins us at the table here it's a
powerful piece and I don't think a lot
of people have ever heard this term
financial abuse so what should they know
about it what are the red flags well a
lot of these things start off subtly so
it's not something maybe that would be a
red flag you you know someone's kind of
monitoring the money or handling the
finances but it really comes down to
control so maybe making
sure you don't have access to certain
accounts or even prohibiting you from
going to school it's a power dynamic in
the same way that domestic violence is I
would bet some people can be financially
abused and don't even know that we
finally financially abused because
they're thinking he or she is just cares
about meaning is taking good care of me
correct and I think historically fifty
years ago that was the case with you
know a lot of families a lot of men were
taking that lead now all states purple
purse initiative is providing domestic
abuse survivors with a step-by-step
financial empowerment curriculum if you
or someone you know is suffering from
any form of domestic abuse reached out
to the National Domestic Violence
hotline at